is what you need to know about what
happened in Congress and why it is
important for the past few weeks
American politicians have been playing
An Almighty game of chicken with the
global economy the country is days away
from its first ever default on its debt
if that happens it will plunge America
into recession jobs lost bills unpaid
Medical Care and Jeopardy and the
economy globally thrown into a genuine
crisis but politicians in there have
found consensus to vote for a deal
hammered out by President Biden and his
political foe house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy it passed by 314 to 117 the
deal to raise the debt ceiling to allow
more borrowing is not perfect for anyone
there are deep reservations about the
level of debt being unsustainable the
bill now heads to Senators they are very
likely to pass it crisis then averted
this game of chicken will be over debt
ceiling raised can kicked down the road